yes go ahead um
all right so in that case uh just make
sure
right okay so hi linda thank you for
being here and uh please go ahead with
your talk
thank you um so let me
share my screen
can you see the slides
okay great so first of all thanks so
much for inviting
me to present here and it's great to see
you again
even though the circumstances are
interesting but okay
okay so the paper that i present today
is joint work with
jesus venezuela verde who's at
university of pennsylvania
and harold ulick who's at the university
of chicago
and well the project is about central
bank digital currency
and so just to bring us all a bit on the
same page what what a cbdc
is first let me say that the the
definition of this term is very much in
flux
so um there are various uh ways
how you can interpret a cdc and the
paper talks about a very particular kind
of a cbdc so we are drawing on the
following definition
by barbarian kumhove who referred to a
cbdc
as a central bank that grants universal
electronic 24 7
national currency denominated and it was
bearing access to its balance sheet
and we will talk about a so-called
account-based cbdc
which can be implemented via accounts
that citizens hold
directly at the central bank so this is
exactly the definition that we will use
today
so imagine you and i we have our bank
account
and not at bank of america maybe but
directly at a central bank
and we have access to this account at
any point in time
okay so the research on cbdc is
currently really
exploding i would say so you can read
about cbdc in the news on at least a
weekly basis
because currently several policy
institutions
are debating the pros and cons of
introducing a cbdc
so amongst others um very leading the
bank of canada and this very gorix bank
the bank of england
but also the bis the ecb the bank of
china imf and g30 and many many more
um so it's very interesting
topic to work at and in
various kinds of ways
so in cbdc you can think of it as
the public response to private
initiatives
private digital currencies or libra or
dm now
and well so the paper joins or
zooms in at a very particular aspect
that a cbdc is going to
bring or is going to change the the
economy or incentives in the economy
namely
um we are going to look at potential
conflicts of interest
that arise when a central bank starts
offering cbdc accounts
so another question so it interrupt
in the private slide when you list sort
of all these uh sort of central banks uh
studying uh so this prospect
what concretely are they thinking about
like of offering directly
digital infrastructure to support it and
also to provide
banking services directly to citizens or
to institutions that then provide their
own
services to to citizens yes so that's a
very good question
um there are so i think one reason or
that they um that they're addressing is
to improve the efficiency of
cross-border payments
um because there's apparently a demand
for that
it's not quite clear to me whether a
central bank should offer such a service
uh my guess is that
we have been observing that um
cryptocurrencies become more and more
popular
as an investment object as a means of
payment and so on
and uh i guess central banks as the
provider of national currency
try to find an answer to that
and a way to
to answer to this is by offering a cbdc
now a cbdc and this is exactly why
i think the paper this paper is
interesting is
a cbtc is not going to be solely
a means of payment but it's going to
also affect
the competition for in the deposit
market between central banks and private
banks for instance
or it's going to affect
the interest that the central bank um
follows follows through with and so
simply because it's going to change the
forces of like even just uh
forex investments like if i want to i
don't know if somebody wants to change a
part of their
deposits into a different denomination
then it would change
like uh how easy it is to do that and
whether somebody wants to do it and so
it might affect these markets
yeah so i guess the way to see it is
that the central bank
enters a new business and therefore
is going to uh start competing with
firms that are already in this business
like payments for instance or offering
deposits
and this is going to change the
landscape thank you
okay so um so there are various ways how
a central bank could be a game changer
in
in a positive or a negative way and um
this paper tries to address potential
conflicts of interest
in which a central bank could here
step into namely traditionally a central
bank objective would be to keep
prices stable so to target inflation at
two percent
this is the case in the euro area it's
the case in the united states
but as soon as a central bank starts
offering cbdc accounts
where small citizens like you and i
we can basically save
save money in the central bank account
and then the central bank
collects all these deposits and will
have to if the central bank
agrees to pay an interest on these
accounts the central bank will have to
earn
uh interest also on these kinds of funds
and how do you earn interest well you
reinvest
and potentially in long-run investments
like long-run assets real estate
infrastructure and so on
um the key point is here the central
bank becomes a so-called financial
intermediate
she intermediates investment and she
conducts maturity transformation
namely if you and i have 24 7 access to
the central bank's balance sheet
yeah short notice demand on short notice
but at the same time the central bank
would invest in the long run
then there's a so-called maturity
mismatch yeah and
a traditional risk that comes with
maturity mismatch
is the proneness of financial
institutions to runs
and a classic question and financial
remediation in general is
the optimal amount of interest rate that
you would pay on such deposits
which we also call optimal risk sharing
but i will go into detail
so all over there will be in this paper
three competing objectives so
keeping prices stable but also offering
optimal let's say interest rate on
deposit accounts
while preventing runs on the central
bank and
the key result in the paper is that we
show an impossibility to
combine or to attain all these three
objectives
at the same time um namely i think the
most
so we call it the cbdc trilemma in order
to
attain you will always have to give up
at least one of these goals
to attain the other two and we believe
the most important one of these is we
show that the central bank could always
offer optimal risk sharing and also
deter runs
but only by credibly giving up uh
the the price stability objective yeah
then
and that's that's important okay so
the key mechanism in the paper is
traditional runs cannot occur on a
central bank because a central bank can
always deliver on
so-called nominal obligations the
central bank can always print money
therefore it cannot be the case that you
go to the bank
and the bank says i'm sorry i cannot
give you one hundred dollars today
they're only ten dollars left that we
can pay you out
this is not happening with a central
bank so a central bank
could always deliver on such promises
but instead we see or we will see today
that
um a run on the central bank can happen
in a different form namely in form of
a run on the price level so basically
exploding inflation
okay why is that
why can't that happen with a
normal uh i mean money that they print
i mean that that the like dollars are
still traded
like on on forex markets like uh
if they print more money like that will
affect
potentially the price of a dollar
against other currencies like
i don't understand how okay and even if
you don't print more money it's already
like uh fluctuating
as a function of the market so and to
understand like why it's different
yes okay so if you let's say it's not a
central bank but a private bank
yeah um a private bank can
run out of assets to liquidate
and then the central bank a private bank
could no longer
hand out okay so yeah so
that i understand for private banks but
i mean the difference between a central
bank
printing paper mommy money versus
printing
digital money there would be no
difference
okay fine so far there's there would be
no difference so far
okay you're making the comparison
between
uh well i was trying to say this the
second point here the the central bank
runs happen in the form of the price
level i mean that's true
i guess for both digital currencies and
for paper money
uh so maybe the
you know the speed at which it happens
may be different i don't know but like
there
is still money printed by the central
bank whether digital your paper and it
still uh
will be traded on forex markets and so
it will
still be subject to those forces i
should maybe say this is a summary slide
and i will explain the mechanism behind
this in in detail
so that sorry that's misunderstanding so
i will come to this in detail
um i'm just summarizing the results okay
so
i i will skip the literature for sake of
time but we will come back to this model
in detail in a second
okay so let me walk you through the
model um we are building on diamond
diploid 1983
so this is a very uh famous banking
model and
it works the following way so there are
three time periods
in which agents basically exist and
agents are given by continuum
which basically means agents are small
um
and so at time zero all ages are
symmetric
agents cannot be distinguished and each
of us
each of us agents endowed with one unit
of a real good and you can think of this
very good as an apple
and we we only care about apples the
consumption of apples
and so in the next time period something
happens namely
uh all of a sudden the agents will not
be symmetric anymore because they learn
something about themselves
namely they learn whether they are the
impatient or the patient
type and think about if if you learn
that you're impatient
you know that you're not going to um
not going to live till the last time
period time too but you you only live
uh up until here which means that you
instantly have to consume
so you you really don't care about
consumption at time two
and if you're a patient type instead
then you can consume at time one and
time two
because you will live a little bit
longer now crucial is that
your type is private information i
cannot see whether you're impatient or
patient
and there's no way to verify the type
okay
what we all have in common is that we
have a strictly increasing and concrete
utility function which basically means
the more apple we apples we consume the
happier we are
and marginally if we already have a
consumed a lot of apples then if you
give me an additional apple i won't be
that much happier
okay and so there's an investment
technology that allows us to
try to transfer apples across time
so recall at time zero each of us is
endowed with one unit
of an apple and we can now invest this
apple in this technology
and this technology pays off the
following way for every apple that you
invest at time zero
the technology returns one apple at the
interim period one
so this basically acts like storage you
can store your apple across time
but now between time one and time two
the technology pays off
a very large return you just imagine
your apple grows
becomes much much bigger and now
diamond and dipfig they show the
following thing so the issue is if each
of
us agents is on his or her own what we
would do
is all of us we would invest our one
apple at time zero into this technology
and then at time one we learn whether
we're the patient or inpatient type
now if we are impatient you know we
instantly have to consume so we
liquidate this technology but then
tragically this technology is only a
storage technology between
zero and one so we only consume one
apple if we are impatient
and if we're instead lucky and turn out
to be patient then we can stay invested
in this technology a bit longer until
time to period two because we can
consume in either period
and then we eat this very large apple
now the thing is
recall that at time 0 we're all
symmetric and
each of us it turns out in the optimum
we would like to ensure at time 0
against the risk of being impatient
because the issue with being impatient
is really that between time 0 and 1 this
technology only
functions as a storage technology so
optimally what diamond and difficult
is we all would like to write contracts
with one another
that assure us against the risk of being
impatient this is called risk sharing
so we all would like to pull our
resources and write a contract so that
if at time one i turn out to be
impatient
i get optimally a little bit more than
one apple yeah i get
slightly bit more and then instead an
agent
that turns out to be patient would get a
little bit less than
this very large apple but we're all
happy with this kind of contract
because we are all agreeing on that this
is optimal to write
at time zero now the issue with such a
contract is also
that okay so first of all diamond
districts show that banks can provide
this kind of risk sharing
they simply pull all the apples at time
zero and invest
for the agents in this technology and
then at time one
if you turn out to be impatient you walk
to the bank and say hey i'm the
impatient type
please give me x one star a little bit
more than one
the problem is types are not verifiable
if i'm the patient type
i can also walk to the bank at time one
and claim that i'm impatient
i can also demand these x1 star and
there's nothing the bank could do
because
the bank cannot distinguish between
patient and inpatient types
and so now if a lot of agents recall
were given by this
measure one of agents if a lot of us
claim to be
the impatient type and demand x1 star
then a so-called bank run happens and
the bank cannot pay out x1 star to all
agents
because this is a real contract the
technology pays in real terms
and this x1 star is is in terms
of apple's written okay and this is now
where our paper comes in
we we are going to exploit that the
technology that
basically transfers apple across time
will stay
in real terms but contracts are offered
in a nominal way
in terms of cbdc
so yes so i was getting confused by the
um so the types
of each agent are not something anyone
can control those are just chosen at
random according to these probabilities
yeah that's random and exogenous but the
agent itself
is a strategic thinker and so
because of that let's call it degree of
freedom then a bank run can happen
yes um let's okay so the inpatient types
they will always consume at time one
because they don't live until time two
but the patient types they strategically
decide
whether to rather consume a time one in
time two
and they will make this decision based
on whether they believe whether they get
more apples at time one
or it's time to okay and the issue is a
bit
if you're the patient type and you
expect a run to happen
then no apples would be left at time two
and then you rather go for
the x1 star at time one and so this
model
i mean it seems it clearly has to do
with what we're talking about here but
these people invented it for what reason
like
they invented it for the reason they
showed to um that
for the two things they showed that
banks basically can
they can offer these kind of optimal
contracts that's the one thing
but they show also in order to offer the
optimal contract the x1 star
the bank has to be fragile
if the bank is stable she has to offer
an x1
and x1 equal to one or less but then she
cannot offer optimal risk sharing
so even in the optimal solution the bank
has to be fragile
so that's a it's a dilemma that's what
they show okay
okay so um we are building on this model
so
it's great that you ask these questions
because that's really important to
understand
so we are building the model on top of
this um
but the contracts that so now the bank
is no longer
a private bank but it is a central bank
and becomes crucial in a moment from now
so the central bank offers nominal
contracts
the nominal contract means denominated
in euro in dollars
but the technology in order to transfer
apples across time
stays the same and it also remains that
at time zero
a single agent is in doubt with one
apple to start with okay
so just for the timing now is the
following way so at time zero the agent
takes this apple and walks to the
central bank and hands over the apple
and then the central bank says great
um in in return for your apple i give
you the following contract
um at time one you're going to learn
what kind of type you are whether you're
patient or impatient
if you're the impatient type and you
have to instantly consume
no problem you can spend m units of cbdc
balances
if you decide to not consume fine as
well then you're going to spend your
money at time two
and you spend a little bit more even m
times one plus
i where i is the nominal interest rate
that the central bank
sets now where does this come from
or let me go on a little bit more here
so this is the perspective of the agent
what the contract allows the agent to do
and important is that the contract here
is now denominated in terms of
cbdc and not apples from the perspective
of the central bank the following
happens
so at time 0 all the agents walk to the
central bank with the apples they hand
over the apple endowment
the central bank takes these apples and
invests in the technology
so far everything is as before now the
difference is
at time one the agents decide whether to
spend
their cbdc balances or not the central
bank observes
how many agents would like to spend yeah
this is going to be an endogenous
variable
it's going to be an equilibrium object
and so depending on
how many agents want to spend the
central bank is now going to select
the fraction of the technology that she
would like to
liquidate and recall that the the
technology is in terms of apples
and spending behavior or the spending
demand will be denominated in cash
so there's a wedge now occurring
now okay so the central bank liquidates
a strategic fraction
of the technology and then sells these
this amount of apples
to the spending agents to the agents
that optimally decide to spend
at a price p1 and so this price becomes
important in the next slide but only
then so what happens with the remaining
technology
the fraction one minus y has not been
liquidated
so it remains invested in the technology
the technology earns the high return
so this is going to be the apple supply
that is sold to the agents that
decide to spend late at time two
and uh so the the spending agent at ten
two then they're going to face a price
p2
and so these objects here they are very
the price levels are
important for the central bank because
under um
the classic central bank objective these
press levels are supposed to stay
stable under all circumstances okay
let's talk about an equilibrium
condition conditioning market clearing
so the market has to clear this means
the price level
at time one has to adjust such that the
total value of all apples that are sold
equals the total amount of cbdc's that
are spent
yeah so n is the fraction of agents that
want to spend their cbdc balances
each of them spends m so this is a
quantity denominated in
say dollars and so the price level p1
adjusts
such that the value of this
strategically
liquidated technology equals the cbdc's
that are
spent at time one and similarly at time
two
the price level p2 has to change such
that total cbdc
spending equals the value of all apples
that are supplied at time 2.
okay so let's first solve these two
equations these are identities
yeah the price the price clears the
market means that the prices adjust
such that these equalities they have to
hold
and now let's let's solve these
equalities for the price levels so
recall that
traditionally for a central bank these
price levels are supposed to remain
stable
but how how do these price levels not
truly adjust
so recall that the spending behavior by
the agents is strategic
and is given by n and the central bank
observes
the spending behavior and strategically
liquidates a fraction of the technology
yeah so certainly what we see here is
that the price level
is also strategic and
adjusts like similar to to residue if
the central bank very freely
liquidates um apple technology
and the same at time too okay so
just this is just to show you that these
price levels they are not set into stone
and this is interesting because here
this is really the perspective of the
central bank
as a private bank you would need to take
these price levels as given
there's no way that a private bank could
manipulate these price levels
but for the central bank this is
possible
now let's look at the perspective of the
individual agent
that decides whether to spend cbdc
balances
rather today than tomorrow okay so the
agent
does not really care about the quantity
of cbdc's that she spends or not
she really cares for the quantity of
apples that cbdc balances can buy
and so what is this quantity now so um
recall that assume assume that the agent
would like to spend at time one
she can spend her cbdc balances of m and
then you would need to
divide by the price level but while this
is just
intuitively equal to the strategically
liquidated quantity
of apple technology divided by all ages
that would like to spend
cbdc's on on airports yeah
so use and similarly at time two
the number of apples that a single agent
can purchase
with his value of cbdc at time 2 is just
the remaining supply of apples divided
by all the agents that decided to spend
their cbdc
late and the crucial insight is here
really
that um we call it a patient agent who
can decide whether to
spend a time one or time too um
she really looks at how many apples do i
get when i spend a time one versus how
many apples will i receive when i spend
that time too
and so we see that on the one hand an
individual optimal decision depends on
how many agents
spend cbdc balances all together because
recall that
if there were only three apples in the
market and then there are 500 people
that are interested in purchasing these
apples then none of us will get a lot of
apples that's just how it is
and this just shows that the central
bank by shortening artificially the
apple supply
will be able to affect the price level
here but in particular also the
individual allocation that an agent
receives
so the central bank by strategically uh
choosing how many uh how much technology
to liquidate
can affect the incentives of individual
agents to spend rather early or late
i think yeah that that's important
okay so let me define what it means
what an equilibrium is here okay so the
central bank
at time zero is going to commit
to a policy so to a money supply and a
liquidation policy
and an interest rate policy for every
possible spending level
uh that can arise yeah and so a
commitment means the central bank is
really going to
go through with her announced policy
um so basically she announced a function
or two functions i and
y that say for every possible spending
level
how many how much of the technology will
the central bank liquidate
and what is the nominal interest rate
that the central bank will pay
on cbdc balances between time one and
time two
a commitment equilibrium now consists of
aggregate spending behavior by the
depositors
a money supply of cbdc a policy y
which is a function of the spending
behavior and an interest rate which is
also a function of spending behavior and
price levels
such that individually these spending
decisions are
optimal um taking as given
the announced policy and the price
levels
then given an aggregate spending
realization of the agents
the centre bank observes the spending
and then in fact
goes through with her announced
liquidation policy as a function of n so
she truly
um takes this n as given and observes
the spending behavior and says okay i'm
going to liquidate then
the according amount of the technology
and we'll pay also an interest rate i of
n
and last then given the realization of
spinning behavior
the liquidated amount of the technology
and nominal interest rates
the price levels are such that the
market clears
and so in this equilibrium definition is
really crucial that
the price levels here are going to
flexibly adjust
according to how many agents decide
to spend and the liquidation policy and
the nominal interest rate
so it generically does not impose
that the prices have to stay fixed
so we do not impose this the classic
central bank goal here at this point in
time
okay then let me briefly talk about what
it means uh
that a bank run occurs so a run occurs
if um also patient agents are spending
so recall that the fraction of agents
that are actually impatient
is only lambda but a patient agent can
strategically decide to spend
also at time one okay
then so given then that the central bank
chooses a particular policy
and why is uh
like that's not is it necessarily a
problem if i don't know
lambda plus one agents
decide to spend i mean that's barely
about what's expected
yeah so we just need um at this point a
notion to pin down what it actually
means what a run is
and then in a moment i will come to the
point where
so recall that only lambda agents really
have to spend early
and one minus lambda agents can
strategically decide whether to spend
early or not
and we will spend the next slides on
looking
under what conditions it is truly
optimal for an agent
for a patient agent to spend early or
not but at this point in time we just
define a central bank run as the
incident where also patient agents
are spending their cbtc accounts early
okay so the question is now to
characterize
under what conditions is it in fact
optimal for for an individual agent
to uh spend balances early or not
okay so um the situation where only
patient types are actually spending
so when n equals lambda this is an
equilibrium
uh only if so you would like to keep now
the patient agents from spending their
cbdc balances
and the way to do that is that
conditional on only inpatient guys
spending
you need to take care that patient guys
get more apples at time two than at time
one
that that's it and because the central
bank commits to such uh
can can basically commit to an according
policy upfront
she can guarantee that this is the case
and
vice versa the question is under what
circumstances would a central bank run
actually be in equilibrium so under what
conditions would it constitute
optimal behavior by patient agents and
that is simply
the case if all agents spent patient or
impatient
then if all agents get more apples at
time one then they would receive at time
two
it's optimal to spend to spend early
it's
simple as that and the question is now
how can the central bank avoid
this to take place
and a clue is already given here
basically because we just have to
remember
the real allocations so the apples about
which the agents care
has to do with yes how many agents
demand um
to spend the cbdc balances but also
depends on the apple supply
which is controlled by the central bank
here
okay so
recall from diamond and diploid we
already know what the social optimum is
uh how much apples the central bank
should optimally be able to promise
inpatient agents at time one now the
question is how can the social optimum
now be implemented
by the central bank
the central bank implements the social
optimum
if conditional on only impatient guy
spending
she has to liquidate sufficiently many
much apple technology
such that she can basically give the
optimal amount of apples
to impatient agents but vice versa
recall the central bank first observes
aggregate spending behavior and
only then needs to decide how many
apples to liquidate
now has to deter the patient guys from
minimum making
the inpatient guys and the way to do
this is to set a liquidation policy
such that if a patient agent tries to
spend early
she takes the center bank takes care
that the agent regrets that
and the way to do this is to give a
patient agent more apples at time two
than at time one
now the implementation goes through the
liquidation policy
so we just solve basically for for
for the liquidation policy we call a
liquidation policy run deterring
if conditional on many agent spending
so if more than the impatient types
spend cbdc balances the central bank
artificially restricts
uh the apple supply in the market and
the way to do this
is simply to um yeah observe spending
behavior
and then artificially reduce the amount
of technology that is liquidated
this is going to translate into very few
apples that are provided at time one
which means that even if all agents run
on the central bank and spend
they're going they're not be able to to
purchase a lot of apples in return
instead they have been better off uh
waiting until time two and spending
their balances there
and now interesting is recall that we
are looking at commitment equilibria
the central bank can announce such a
policy
which is basically a schedule for every
possible
spending behavior between london one she
announces this upfront at time zero
before agents decide what to do at time
one
and this just means if the central bank
[Music]
implements such a run deterrent or
announces such a undeterring policy
then at time one if you learn that
you're a patient
and you believe that the central bank is
going to go through with her policy
then you know that you will be better
off to not spend early but rather spend
a time too because you will get more
apples
so this just means that this threat here
is never implemented in equilibrium
okay so i will come now to the main
result um
and this basically is the first part of
the trilemma
it just says that every policy which
um which goes the following way so if
only inpatient
types are spending cbdc balances at time
one
the central bank is going to liquidate
enough technology
such that every agent receives the
social
optimum amount of apples but if more
than the impatient types are spending so
if n
is larger lambda then the central bank
is going to liquidate
um not as much of the technology and
will take care
that you basically regret your spending
decision if you're
a patient guy such a policy deters
central bank grants
and implements the social optimum
dominant strategies yeah so runs do not
occur
and the social optimum always attains
because
only inpatient guys will walk to the
bank at time one to spend cbdc balances
the central bank liquidates the optimal
amount and then this is done
there's a flip side to that namely if
the central bank
liquidates only a short or a small
proportion of the investment
this is going to translate one to one to
a very large high price level
yeah so um this flip side is that the
implementation of a rendering policy
requires that price levels are very
large
and in particular they are flexible or
potentially flexible in the spending
behavior of the agents
so this is the main result
this basically says the optimum is
always implementable
runs do not occur but the center bank
has to threaten in a credible way
with inflation and only then
um will a run never occur and then this
inflation threat
will not have to be executed at an
equilibrium
the direction's wrong but why is uh
why is liquidating you know certain
amount of like a large fraction of the
technology
going to cause the price to go up i mean
usually
liquidations drive prices gone down
i'm just i'm just confused about the
direction
yes um the um the uh
okay so the intuition is um you have to
think about the wedge between
um so the contract is
denominated in dollars and the
technology is denominated in apples
so the central bank does not restrict
you from spending your cbtc
accounts right if a lot of agents decide
to spend their cbdc
units on apples this is totally fine for
the central bank
but what the central bank does is there
may be 500 agents that want to spend
their cbdc
and the central bank only offers three
apples this means that the equilibrium
price in if you look at the market
clearing equation yeah so if the
left-hand side
if the supply of cbdc is huge and only
needs a very short supply of apples
the price level will be gigantic so the
price of apples is going to be huge
yeah and intuitively it just means that
um
it i understand but so i thought that
liquidating technology meant
that uh the central bank is
uh selling apples it owns in return
for currency which means that there are
going to be more apples
available to be sold
the prices go down then not up
yes so i think um the liquidation policy
has to adhere
in upper bound so it has to be
sufficiently small and then the price is
large
okay fine sure yeah yeah okay i think
because i think you got it right
okay so um um
i only have a few minutes left so let me
uh
show you a couple of more results so
first of all and let me say that
uh the result that i just shown you is
um
is good and bad news at the same time um
but so in order to implement the social
optimum and deter runs the center band
will have to sacrifice
price stability but price stability is
the classic goal of central banks
so what we are going to do in the
remaining part of the paper in my three
minutes left or two
we are going to impose an exogenous
price stability objective so we are
basically now
uh of this tremendous i've shown you
that
we can achieve these two goals by
sacrificing
the last one we are now going to impose
this third goal and we will see whether
we can achieve optimal risk sharing
or whether we can deter runs on the
central bank
okay so we need a notion of price
stability now
we would say that a central bank policy
is stable at a goal
p-bar if the price level at time 1
remains at this constant gold p-bar no
matter how many agents spend
so if maybe only inpatient guys spend
maybe all of the agents are spending
the price level has to be at p bar at
this goal
this basically means means that you pin
down near the left hand side
and so the central bank is going to
observe spending behavior
takes the goal as given and then
liquidates accordingly
okay so what happens then
we have to change the equilibrium
condition a little bit but essentially
what it means is that
the liquidation policy of the central
bank and also the nominal interest rate
now adjust flexibly to spending behavior
and the price level recall that in the
other equilibrium definition it was the
other way around
there the price level would adjust to
the liquidation policy and the nominal
interest rate
okay so just let me uh characterize
what stable policies mean we can show
that
a policy that is stable at time worn at
a goal p-bar
requires the central bank to liquidate
uh
in a constant proportion of the
aggregate spending level
and requires this constant proportion
for all possible spending levels
so just think of a straight line
think of a straight line for all
possible spanning levels
uh the center bank liquidates this
constant proportion
and now the issue is however that um the
central bank can never liquidate more
than the entire technology
so there's a feasibility constraint
and this means that the real allocation
at time one so the number of apples that
you can promise an agent at time one
under a p1 stable policy is first of all
constant
under p1 stable policy but it's also
bounded from above by one
yeah because you cannot liquidate more
than one here there's just
one one technology okay
this is tragic because the social
optimum requires an x1 star greater than
one
so we already hear of the second part of
the trilemma
saying that if you want to implement a
p1 stable policy
you will not attain the social optimum
this is not possible here
but vice versa it is the case that
you will always be able to deter central
bank runs
why simply because the real allocation
at time one
is too small patient agents would not be
interested
in spending their cbdc balances at time
one under a p1 stable policy
yeah so this the second part of the
trilemma
um under a p1 stable policy runs do not
occur
but you do not attain the social optimum
and now
in order to to i mean the central bank
would like to
soften maybe the price stability
requirement a little bit
because the central bank really would
like to implement the social optimum
and so what this is what we do now so we
say
a partially p stable policy is a policy
that
keeps the price level stable for our
spending levels
or requires the liquidation of the
entire technology
yeah and so by partial stability
the central bank can uh has a little bit
more flexibility in its liquidation
policy
so she can basically implement steeper
slopes
and a steeper slope is important because
if only inpatient guys are spending
the central bank here will be able to
liquidate enough technology
to to supply the social optimum but here
is the flip side
there exists a range of possible
spending levels
for which the central bank has to
liquidate the entire technology at time
one meaning that for agents that spend
later time too
there's no technology left yeah so
agents that then spend a time too
they would receive zero apples
but these agents are sophisticated
they're strategic so they know at time
one when they need to size strategically
whether to spend rather early or late
they know that conditional on many agent
spending there would be no apples left
so this just means that central bank
runs are back on the table
yeah under um under a partially price
stable central bank policy
there are now two equilibria there's a
good equilibrium in which
no run occurs so this means that
a spending behavior is low in this
no-run equilibrium in fact the social
optimum can be implemented and the price
level is stable
but then there is a run equilibrium in
which the social optimum is not
implemented
patient and inpatient agents would like
to spend at time one
so early and the price level goal is not
attained
okay so i'm out of time let me wrap up
i've shown you a nominal banking model
for a central bank
the central bank can always deliver on
its nominal obligations simply because
the central bank has the power to set
the price level
uh runs can nevertheless still happen
because um
there will be runs on the on the price
level that are possible
and what we basically show is that the
central bank can never attain
all her three objectives at the same
time so
attaining price stability offering the
social optimum
and deterring runs will not be possible
thank you so much
um um
so i have a few more questions to ask i
don't know if uh insomnia and jonathan
have any questions
yeah sorry for calling out by name
yeah you do have one question so this
model of uh
um three-step three-time step model i
forgot the names of the two
dimension i think yeah so how
i mean how imperfect is it i mean like
you know people make decisions
all the time right not just once and
that's it so
how empirically validated is it for
i know standard banks are there you know
more of sophisticated models that people
should want to study and try to kind of
uh start from where you
so from your paper
so let me say first i think this is one
of the big banking
bank round papers so it's um people
always call it the uh
the seminar paper on bank rounds i think
it's a very important paper
because it's very simplistic it has
thousands of extensions
so it's really in finance everyone
knows this model and of course it's a
very simplified and
many kind of ways so
usually you would not think about the
assets of being risk-free like this
returns paid for sure
there can be various time periods and so
on but
what this paper really accomplishes is
it shows in a very elegant way
that um banks can basically
bring something to the table they can
offer these optimal uh
risk sharing contracts and
i i think the the original result that
banks have to be fragile in order to
offer the optimum that's very elegant um
and um well it's
you know it's an important banking model
i think the um simplistic model is very
uh
[Music]
i think it's always good to aim at
simplistic things and then extend from
there
it's much yeah
that's my personal opinion i don't know
but it's a very important banking model
um so another question is
so uh in uh
when you have these uh central banks
considering
cbdc's uh i presume
there are some teams somewhere
discussing should we do this should we
do that
uh you know kind of trying to make some
considerations
do you have a sense of are these people
talking about
technological solutions are they talking
about policy solutions
what are they how are they spending
their
uh thinking cycles like for instance you
know
knowing about this paper you know with
them help
them a lot or maybe they're they have
policies dictated by
politics maybe or or or philosophy
rather than here
some some parts of the economy are have
maybe more to do with philosophy than
the theorems right you just
pick like a political uh part of the
spectrum and then you know there's
economic
economic kind of uh set up to go with it
or are they like talking about
technology and you know how to deploy
these things in the real world
have you spent any time talking to these
people or investing
yes so um let me start with so i'm not a
central banker but
um okay so uh i think classically
the the research departments and central
banks they have different units
um some units that are interested in
in interest rate and monetary policy
implications um other departments that
are interested
in technology and payments and so on
departments that are interested in
competition aspects
and so the the paper here only zooms in
at
one particular question but uh central
banks are
debating so they they are um certainly
very critical
in in many kinds of ways so they are
really interested right now in
the in all kinds of economic
implications
um how a central bank uh however cbdc
could change
um the economy affect the economy so
in a companion paper what my
co-authors and i are doing is we look
at how the introduction of a cbdc
changes the the situation for private
banks because
private banks also offer deposit
contracts
and then private banks will have
competition from central banks
and this can be dramatic if the central
bank is for some reason
perceived to be more uh stable or to to
provide safer contracts
then um potentially the central bank is
going to absorb the deposits from the
private banks
or in order to prevent that private
banks will have to raise their interest
rates
um and and so on um so this one aspect
that is
uh that people talk about um there is
um the payment technology aspect which
i'm
not fully knowledgeable about but this
is certainly discussed so
how a cbdc can enable or make
cross-border payments more efficient
uh how these settlements can work
exactly in detail but
this item i'm not in these a
cross-border payment system so
um but yeah so i think this is very
uh highly debated um
in in these institutions that i
mentioned at the beginning of the
presentation
um critically and uh
potentially also favorably um
yeah um but but let me say that so in
these central banks
there are a lot of researchers in fact
working so a lot of economists
and i think they are um i believe that
they know my research
uh i i because this project is um
is associated with the ecb so it's the
lanfalusi project and
so i think they know the project but
yeah
yeah okay thank you actually very
interesting
um okay so
um yeah thank you so much uh enough
putting together this uh this talk
and uh uh yeah workshop continues for
another two days with four talks today
and um i look forward to see you all
there
all right so we're done for today bye
everybody thank you thank you alessandra
bye-bye